Alright,
people were taking a break from politics
this weekend we're going to focus on the
f word.
That's right food.
They say,
you are what you eat,
and if that's true,
a lot of us are half hot dog,
half pizza and half ice cream.
I know that that's three halves,
but we're a pretty fat group of people
these days.
Every week there's a new diet to follow,
a new oil to avoid or a new super food
that'll change your life.
Then the week after that we usually find
out that the new revolutionary diet will
actually make you gain weight.
You actually need that oil to live and
the superfood does absolutely nothing at
an endless slew of magazines to the
countless websites and blogs devoted to
keeping you clicking on the newest fad
and it becomes almost impossible to
figure out what you should eat.
As those of you follow me on social
media.
No,
I'm in the midst of a little diet
myself.
Right now.
I'm doing a slow carb Paleo Diet,
which is a slightly modified version of
what form of Rubin report guest Tim
Ferriss helped popularize.
Basically,
I'm eating only meat,
fish and veggies with no sugar and very
limited carbs.
I'm even putting grass fed butter in my
coffee to get an extra boost of fat and
energy in the morning as I'm taping this
direct message.
I've lost about five pounds in 10 days,
although I've also punched for random
strangers on the street for looking at
me the wrong way,
but as they say,
everything in moderation.
Of course,
what you should or shouldn't put in your
body isn't just about weight.
It's also about your mind,
and this is a place where the science is
actually pretty solid.
The foods that we eat or don't eat can
have a tremendous effect on our brain
itself,
right down to our ability to think as
we've seen a spike in degenerative brain
diseases such as Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's disease,
which are just two of the many forms of
dementia.
It's becoming clearer and clearer that
fueling our brains with the right foods
and avoiding the wrong ones are a key to
brain health.
So much of what we talk about on this
show is related to clear and critical
thinking.
While we may not think about how the
food that we eat is affecting our brains
on a daily basis,
feeding our brains the right foods is as
important,
actually possibly more important than
feeding our brains the right
information.
So this week we're going to learn some
information on what we should feed our
brains so that we're optimized to engage
in intellectual battles in the best way
possible.
Joining me to discuss this is an old
friend of the show and author of the new
book Genius Foods Max Lewkowicz.
Now,
excuse me,
while I put grass fed butter on an
avocado,
sprinkled with Goji Berries.
Joining me today is a truth seeker,
a self experimenter of brain food expert
and author of the upcoming book Genius
Foods.
Max Ligonier,
welcome back.
Thanks so much for having to the Rubin
report.
This is a back,
although most of my audience now will
not know you from the Rubin report,
but you used to do the old rubin report.
It seems like a real lifetime ago,
doesn't it?
Back back in the day when it was a panel
show,
it was a panel show years ago on t y,
t I don't even know what we're doing.
I have almost no recollection of my life
at that time.
It's,
you know,
the,
every time that I was on it though,
I would always have such a good time and
I always would think to myself like how
good you are at what you do and so I'm
just so honored to be here in this new
set and to see your success.
Like,
you know,
the fact that you've just blown up.
It's awesome.
Cool.
Well thank you and I feel the same and
I'm glad that our paths have sort of a,
you know,
I've been on parallel tracks kind of
growing together.
You have a new book coming out,
which we're going to talk about shortly.
The last time I saw you though,
uh,
was about two or two and a half years
ago.
You had me eat some really nasty stuff
on camera that you felt.
I don't even know why you had me eat it,
but you wanted me to.
What?
What did we eat?
Because you're doing a lot about food,
so you're,
you're testing this stuff out.
All the time.
We ate,
we ate Natto,
which
is a fermented soybean dish that is very
commonly consumed in Japan and that was
my first time ever trying it because I
think,
yeah,
back where your old set was,
we were like a few blocks away from like
a Japanese market and I was like,
wow,
what a great place to go and try to find
this food that I've heard so much about
because of its purported health
benefits,
but I never tasted it and it's known for
being particularly gnarly.
Like it smells like dirty socks.
And I knew that you were back at the
studio and I was like,
what?
You know,
there's no better time to try this
gnarly food than with my friend Dave
Ruben.
So I brought it back and we tried it.
And uh,
yeah,
I don't think you were that night
two,
it was pretty nasty.
Mean I'm,
I'm a pretty good eater and we're going
to get a lot into the different types of
things that you should be eating.
Fermented food,
obviously good,
but it was kinda like beans in this
gooey sticky sauce and it stunk to high
hell you're saying it was good for my
brain.
It's very good.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean,
you know,
it's the top known source of vitamin K
two,
which is a really important vitamin for
a vitamin for maintaining calcium
homeostasis in the body.
Basically keeping calcium and the parts
of your body where calcium should be
like your bones and your teeth and out
of your soft tissues like your kidneys
and your arteries and stuff like that.
Um,
there's really good research on vitaminK
two and yeah,
I just,
you know,
natural is one of these foods.
They eat it in one of the world's blue
zones.
So I just figured why not give it a try?
I would say it has the consistency of
like baked beans with a little bit of
like personal
can swirled together,
which is obviously not appealing.
It's quite horrific.
I should've had something here for you
to taste on.
Camera don't have been awesome.
Like kicking the ball back.
Maybe.
Maybe next time.
So first I thought,
well we start off with before we get to
the book is I think sort of what you're
doing is interesting because it kind of
parallels what I'm doing here where
we're watching mainstream media crumble
and people are coming to people like me
perhaps in and Shapiro and Joe Rogan and
all these alternate to hear about news
and I also think that's happening in the
food world and the Diet world as well,
where you used to maybe watch the
nightly news to find out what you're
supposed to eat,
what the latest fad is,
what oils you're not supposed to have,
et Cetera,
et Cetera.
And now people are going to people like
Joe Rogan,
who I just mentioned,
Tim Ferriss,
people like you.
Did you sort of see that thing coming
and that's why you started getting into
this world and we'll talk a little bit
about your personal reasons why you got
into it.
Just a sec.
Yeah.
No,
it's an amazing point.
I feel that,
you know,
look,
we live in a time,
you know,
and in a world where we have all of the
world's information at our fingertips at
any given time with our smart phones,
you know,
and research is out there,
information wants to be free so,
you know,
whereas prior generations I feel like
know could have,
could have only received health
information from the doctor or nutrition
information from the nutritionist.
Um,
today,
you know,
I think things are different where
people that are passionate and that,
uh,
do their homework in a way.
I'm not just talking about going to know
media for their health information,
but you know,
pub med is something that anybody can
search.
It's,
you know,
the research is out there.
Not Everybody's going to be qualified to
the degree that they can,
you know,
understand,
for example,
medical literature or even cut through
the jargon.
But,
um,
there's a lot that people can glean from
what is readily available.
I mean,
one of the ways that I try to tell
people to become educated about health
and science and research is to look at
websites that put out university press
releases that often accompany studies
like science daily.
For example,
our medical express.
You know,
oftentimes when a study's released,
the university will write a press
release that basically has the gist of
what the study basically found in
layman's terms and that's often what
journalists will use to write pieces for
the Huffington post or fast company.
So what I tell people to do is cut out
the middle man,
go to the press releases,
read them,
then go to the research article,
compare what you read in Layman's terms
in the press release to the research
article and that can actually help you
interpret research.
So the average person,
they'll obviously,
it's not going to do all that legwork
and I think that's where someone like
you comes in going,
I will sit down and read all this stuff
and now distill it to you in a way that
makes it.
Yeah.
Well,
my background,
I mean,
you know,
before,
before really diving into a health and
nutrition and fitness,
I was a journalist at current TV,
which was my first job out of college.
And so getting to work with the
journalists there,
um,
you know,
peabody award winning journalists,
award winning storytellers.
Um,
it gave me a sense of how to ask
questions,
how to pick my sources,
and then when I became interested in
nutrition and health,
um,
you know,
I kind of knew not only where to look
but how to look and um,
and yeah,
and you know,
my unique job gave me the time and the
ability and you know,
my personal circumstances.
And so yeah,
I don't expect everybody to do their own
research,
but I do think that people should do
their own research.
I do think that the,
that the,
you know,
healthcare healthcare is something that
we like to pretend that we're able to
sort of offload to our healthcare
providers.
Right?
But you don't go to a doctor to be
healthy.
You go to a doctor to become free of
disease or to have a disease treated.
I think healthcare really is something
that,
um,
you know,
starts in the kitchen and in the gym and
it's something that we,
you know,
that we have to imbue our lives with day
to day.
Yeah.
And I want it to start with that because
I think it sets the table properly
because I know on youtube there's a
million people talking about health and
diets and all that stuff and I want
people to understand that you're
somebody that I know has been in this
for a long time actually doing the
research.
So let's go to that,
that personal circumstance part that you
mentioned,
you sort of got into this,
uh,
it's probably only about five years ago
with the circumstances with your mom at
all.
Can you take it from there?
Yeah.
So when I left current TV to sort of
figure out where I was going to go with
my career,
um,
it was sort of in that downtime in
between jobs that um,
my mom started displaying very strange
symptoms that I couldn't explain.
I mean memory,
no problems with her memory.
She complained of brain fog and she also
had changes to her gate that were very
apparent.
I mean,
my mom is a spirited New Yorker.
New Yorkers walk very fast.
They walk everywhere.
Um,
and my mom ran a business so cognitively
she was always very sharp and
essentially what we,
what we saw is that my mom's cognition
took like a,
it just seemed to have like,
you know,
like a web browser with too many open
tabs is how I describe it,
you know,
it just,
like a stuttering frame rate on a
youtube video with a poor Internet
connection.
And my mom's gate changed where,
you know,
before she was a very fast walker,
she almost developed sort of like a
shuffle.
And both of these strange symptoms
seemed to come on at once.
And I had no prior family history of any
neurodegenerative disease.
Dementia to me was not a term that I was
familiar with.
I didn't know what else hammers disease
was actually when I thought about the
word dementia,
the one I thought about the character
from the addams family movie,
you know,
like it was like cousin it's or festers
like crush or something.
Her name was dementia,
which was actually pretty funny.
But yeah,
so coinciding with like my ignorance a,
I had the time to go with my mom to some
of the top neurology departments in the
country.
We're very fortunate to be able to do
that.
We went to Nyu,
Columbia in New York,
Johns Hopkins in Baltimore,
the Cleveland Clinic.
I'm all in hopes of trying to find some
kind of diagnosis for my mom,
see what was going on.
And it was in 2011 at the Cleveland
Clinic,
um,
where my mom was diagnosed with a
neurodegenerative disease for the first
time and she was prescribed drugs for
both Parkinson's disease and Alzheimer's
disease.
And at that moment,
I mean my world pretty much stopped.
Like I,
it was.
I'm a pretty chill guy that that weekend
or that week in Cleveland,
it was the first time in my that I'd
ever had a panic attack.
I was just so freaked out by the
possibility that my mom had this fatal
disease for which there is no cure or
particularly meaningful treatment.
And I basically became unable to think
about anything else,
let alone my career.
I ended up,
you know,
my mom started taking the drugs.
I ended up coming back to La to try to,
you know,
look for jobs and do what it is that you
do when you live in La and you're a
journalist on TV.
And I basically became unable to think
about anything other than nutrition,
you know,
every waking minute that I wasn't,
doing something career related.
I was in pub Med digging through the
research and what I think really
motivated this journey for me was the
fact that what I uncovered in the
research was a stark contrast to the,
you know,
what neuroscientists Norman doidge calls
neurological nihilism to the,
to the despair and bleakness that I
experienced in those doctor's offices
with my mom.
Can you,
can you describe what that is?
What are they actually telling you?
Well,
yeah,
so I,
I call it diagnose and adios.
Basically there's a,
there's a,
there's a quote that I learned that is
circulated amongst medical school
medical school students that
neurologists don't treat disease.
They admire it.
That's because the brain is a mystery
for the most part.
I mean we know quite a bit about the
brain,
which is surprising,
but there's a lot more unknowns than
knowns at this point,
and treatments for neurological diseases
are very limited.
You know,
there's no approved drug for Alzheimer's
disease that has a disease modifying
treatment.
They only act as bandaids,
like chemical,
bandaids,
essentially that work to sort of
artificially boost neurotransmitters in
the brain,
but they do nothing to solve the
underlying pathology.
And you know,
drug trials are notoriously bad.
Pfizer just announced,
for example,
that they're going to stop pursuing a
pharmaceutical treatments for
Alzheimer's disease because treating the
quest to find a drug to treat the
disease has like a 99 point six,
two percent fail rate that's worse than
any other disease.
So meaning that they are getting out of
the game altogether,
they view this as something that can't
be solved via drugs.
I mean,
that sounds incredible.
I don't know how often that happens with
other diseases.
That sounds.
That sounds pretty staggering.
Yeah.
I mean another huge pharmaceutical
company basically recently announced
this.
The same thing.
X event.
Um,
yeah.
It's a massive fell.
Right?
So think about it from the perspective
perspective of an investor or are you
going to invest in an Alzheimer's or in
any drug trial that has,
you know,
a 99 point six percent fail rate.
It's,
you know,
it's just not a smart investment.
And that's why Alzheimer's disease
research is criminally underfunded or I
shouldn't say criminally if it makes
sense,
although it's tragic because you know,
if,
if there was a pill tomorrow that I
could give my mom that would help in a
meaningful way.
Of course I would want it.
I want it for all the 5 million people
in America that are suffering from
Alzheimer's disease,
you know,
because I can bring almost anything back
to politics.
It's like this is a good argument for
publicly funded scientific research
because it doesn't have to deal with the
bottom line where you're saying,
yeah,
these companies,
they have to deal with a bottom line and
shareholders and they have to then stop
at some point if,
if they can't get far enough where
something publicly funded,
they can keep going to the science
hopefully.
Although you found that there are some
other ways to deal with this and that's
really what changed your life.
Yeah.
So I,
you know,
I saw on the one hand I became really
interested in learning about,
you know,
potential diet and lifestyle
interventions that I could throw my
mom's way to sort of help her.
But then at the same time I became
really conscious of my own brain health
because I learned that changes begin in
the brain decades before the first
symptom of Alzheimer's disease,
which is just one form of dementia.
But even Parkinson's disease,
by the time you show your first symptom
of Parkinson's disease,
half of the neurons involved in
movement,
uh,
in that part in the part of the brain
associated with Parkinson's disease are
already dead.
So these are not,
you know,
like any chronic disease,
these are not diseases that develop
overnight.
They take years,
if not decades to develop.
And I became really interested in doing
what I could do in my own life to
maximize my brain health so that I might
not have to deal with what it is at my
mom dealing with
out.
We'll go from there.
We'll slightly shift to your book.
Obviously this is all intertwined.
The,
this is the advanced copy of the book
comes out in a couple of weeks and I was
reading a little bit and I just thought
that the opening alone was really
perfect.
So I'm just going to read the opening
paragraph,
unless do you want to read it in your
own voice?
Maybe.
Maybe you should.
You know what?
I'm going to let you read the opening
paragraph of your book.
Oh Man,
I thought it was pretty beautiful.
Thank you so much.
I'm nestled within your skull mere
inches from your eyes are $86,
million of the most efficient
transistors in the known universe.
This neural network is you running the
operating system.
We know his life and no computer yet
conceived,
comes close to it's awesome
capabilities,
forged over millions and millions of
years of life on earth.
Your brain is capable of storing nearly
8,000
iphones worth of information.
Everything you are do love,
feel care for long for and aspire to is
enabled by an incredibly complex
invisible symphony of neurological
processes,
elegant,
seamless,
and blisteringly fast.
When scientists try to simulate just one
second of a human brains abilities,
it took supercomputers 40 minutes to do
so.
So yeah,
I mean the brain is who we each are heir
to this amazing birthright,
forged over millions of millions,
millions and millions of years of life
on earth.
And yet the modern world is fighting it
at every turn.
You know from the toxic industrial
products that have saturated the food
supply to the dietary advice that we've
been given for decades to now.
The fact that the pendulum is swinging
the other direction and people are,
it's sort of like a dietary free for
all,
you know,
so.
All right.
Let's shift my dietary.
I want to talk about your.
So you know that at the moment I'm in
the middle of this sort of slow carb
diet is high fat,
no sugar,
no carb diet.
I've actually in about a,
as of this taping in about nine days,
I've lost about three pounds.
Pretty good.
I actually feel pretty good.
I have these brief moments where I want
to punch random people.
I think I'm being a little meaner on
twitter that I go would be for real.
I mean like there's just like a little
bit of mood stuff,
but my energy feels pretty good.
I'm not getting that sort of crashed
from coffee that you might get at like
2:00.
That then has people drinking all kinds
of chemicals that after there 2:30
feeling or whatever that is.
So I basically feel pretty good.
It's pretty much just meat and fish and
veggies and a lot of butter.
And you said,
you said to me right before we started
maybe maybe the butter grass fed butter.
Yeah,
well,
grass fed butter is definitely good.
You know,
I mean,
there's definitely trace nutrients in
it.
Vitamin K two,
which we talked about earlier,
Cla,
which is being studied as a potential
cancer fighter and fat burner.
Um,
but it's uh,
you know,
one of the hallmarks of a healthy food
is nutrient density.
When you take any concentrated fat
butter,
oil,
they're not very nutrient dense.
They've got a lot of calories,
nine calories per gram,
a tablespoon of oil has a hundred and 40
calories.
And um,
and uh,
yeah,
and it's just,
it's a lot of calories with very little
nutrients.
And there's,
you know,
on butter alone,
there's not a lot of evidence to say
that butter improves fat burning or
brain health or anything like that.
So,
you know,
I like to tell people that,
consuming fat,
the high fat,
low carb Diet,
if you already have fat,
all you need is a low carb.
You know,
your body has the fat to burn.
So nobody's good.
Go to your fat probably in your stomach
area as opposed to what a lot of people
are doing with these diets is you're
loading up on fat to sort of get the
bike going on fat and then the hope is
that then it to your.
Everybody's going to want to burn the
fat that you're consuming before it
burns the fat that you have around your
waist and the point of a diet like this,
I would assume is to lose some of the
fat around your,
around your waist.
Yeah,
I mean that's why I think this
conversation is so interesting because
I,
you know,
Ferris,
Tim Ferris,
he's the one that sort of did this low
carb thing first or the four hour body,
whatever it is.
And it's like,
well,
all right.
He's focusing on that part,
the weight loss part.
So I am seeing some results on that
front.
You're focusing on the brain part,
which is also very important to me.
You know,
you know,
I'm someone that likes to know what I'm
talking about and be able to have clean
thoughts at all.
Of course I liked,
I mean I like to focus on the weight
part too.
I mean that's a concern for I think
everybody and it's a good way also to
just have this conversation about
nutrition and healthy eating.
Um,
you know,
when you start a low carb diet,
you're going to lose a lot of water
weight at first because what you're
doing is you're depleting the amount of
glycogen stored in your muscles.
Glycogen is basically how your muscles
and liver stores sugar,
but for every gram of glycogen in your
muscles store,
you also store about three to four grams
of water.
So that's why once you start depleting
the glycogen from your muscles with
vigorous exercise or just by not eating
a lot of carbs,
you lose a lot of water weight very
quickly.
And that's also why when people stop
eating low carb and go back to eating a
higher carb diet,
their weight just shoots up because
their muscles end up storing all that
glycogen along with all that,
you know,
with four parts water for every one
gram,
one part of,
of sugar storage.
I think what we're going to have to do
is like in a month from now,
if I can keep running with this thing,
I'll have to have you and Ferris on
together.
You guys can like poke me,
you can poke my brain area.
He could poke my stomach,
will figure out.
Sounds great.
What happened here?
All right,
so enough about my,
my diet people.
I guess we'll see the results right here
on the youtube.
Um,
okay.
So you start realizing that the,
the,
the medicine for dementia or
Alzheimer's,
these cognitive,
uh,
degenerative diseases is not quite
there.
You start changing your own diet,
but then also realized,
well this is how I can also sort of
helped my mom and help other people like
it.
So what are some of the first things
that you realized that do,
that we as people have generally are
doing wrong?
Yeah,
well definitely,
you know,
my diet used to be dictated by um,
what sort of conventional wisdom was
surrounding a healthy diet.
So I used to build my base,
my diet or on grains.
I used to basically Shaun White carbs,
you know,
white rice,
white bread as if it were some kind of
toxin,
but if you put a huge bowl of brown rice
in front of me,
I would go to town on it often asking
for seconds,
you know,
every meal had to include a grain and I
would notice that my energy levels
throughout the day always felt like a
rollercoaster,
you know,
I couldn't really go many hours after
waking without eating something right
away.
And in between lunch and dinner I was
off.
I would often find myself starving.
And,
you know,
when I started looking into the
research,
I realized that there's really no good
evidence to say that grains improve
health.
I mean certainly if you're metabolically
healthy,
you can tolerate grains,
which is not the case for 50 percent of
the people living in America that are
either pre diabetic or diabetic and have
essentially become glucose or
carbohydrate intolerant.
If you're healthy though,
you can eat,
you know,
rice and you can certainly incorporated
as a means of improving a athletic
performance.
Um,
but that was really the first thing that
I did.
You know,
because my dad was never very high in
added sugars.
I started cutting out the breads and
rices and all that stuff and the pastas
and I noticed that my energy levels
just,
you know,
not only did they go through the roof,
but there were more stable throughout
the day.
Um,
and you know,
without even really trying my body
composition changed.
I started losing fat,
which is something that was just like a
side bonus.
And again,
you know,
the recommendations to eat grains
because many people do consider them
healthy.
You know,
how could keen wire brown rice peanuts
but healthy,
um,
come from misguided,
you know,
nutrition policy over the past 50 years
that have really been attributed to the
Mediterranean dietary pattern.
That's this nebulous idea of how people
in the Mediterranean eat 'em because
epidemiological observational population
based research shows that they have
reduced rates of cardiovascular disease
and neurological disease.
But when you look at randomized control
trials,
which are the kinds of trials required
to prove cause and effect,
there is no good evidence to say that
grains improve health.
In fact,
when you look at research controlled
trials with people with prediabetes or
type two diabetes or obesity,
low carb diets seem to win most of the
time when compared to a standard low
fat,
you know,
conventional wisdom,
conventional dietary wisdom.
Yeah.
So let's back up for a second because
you said something really interesting
that just sort of rolled off your
tongue.
It seems pretty freaking staggering and
scary.
Fifty percent of Americans are either
pre diabetic or diabetic.
That's what the latest statistics.
So what is actually,
what is prediabetic actually mean?
So when you're pre diabetic,
your blood sugar is higher than it
should be.
That's what a doctor will measure.
And they'll say you should probably,
you know,
change up your diet because you are at
risk for becoming a type two diabetic.
Um,
it's sort of like this middle ground
where,
um,
yeah,
your blood sugar is higher than it
should be.
Do they know how much that number has
changed over the years?
I suspect since probably the fifties
when we started all this process,
food and sugars and all that stuff that,
that,
and soft drinks and everything else,
that must have tremendously increased
that.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's,
it's skyrocketed in tandem with,
you know,
the obesity rates in this country.
Sixties,
two thirds of people are either
overweight or obese,
um,
and they've kind of risen in tandem with
one another.
Uh,
and the only thing that can really
explain it is the environment,
you know,
because our genes certainly haven't
changed over the past 100 years as a,
as a population.
So what has.
Well,
the food supply,
um,
and you know,
there's a lot of zealotry in the world
of nutrition.
It's a very,
you know,
people tend to feel very religious of
other nutritious,
uh,
beliefs.
Um,
but you know,
in general what I think most people
would agree on is that there is become a
ubiquity of hyper processed foods that
are rich in both readily,
easily digestible carbohydrates,
pulverized grains,
stripped of their nutrients and added
fats.
And you know,
both of these foods put together a,
basically create a stereotypical junk
food.
And that's really what most people are
consuming these days.
I mean 60 percent of calories that
Americans consume come from these exact
kinds of foods,
ultra processed foods.
I always think of that commercial.
I don't know if they're still running
it,
but it's with a Larry the cable guy for
prior Lasek OTC and you know,
he's out there eating the hot dogs and
all this stuff and he's basically like,
you can eat whatever you want as long as
your private sec otc.
Like it's like the pill is the answer,
you know,
he's a pretty heavy guy in the first
place.
I have no problem with him,
but it's like that,
that we go to do whatever the hell you
want.
And then here's our magic pill for it.
Probably not.
The best way to be dealing with are not.
No,
not the best way at all.
I mean,
and the thing is,
you know,
once you've.
One of the main drivers of of type two
diabetes and insulin resistance,
which category,
which is one of the sort of,
which is the hallmark of type two
diabetes,
is chronically elevated levels of
insulin which could precede a diagnosis
of prediabetes by a decade.
So I mean people are walking around
eating on average 300 grams of
carbohydrates per day.
Exactly from the kinds of foods that
we're talking about,
hyper processed foods and it's just
doing a number on our metabolisms are
waistlines and genius foods we explore,
you know,
what it's doing to our brains and our
mental function and our moods.
Yeah.
So that's really where I want to focus
on this because I think that's your
expertise and I just find that
fascinating because I think there's a
lot of things happening right now that
might be changing some of our brain
chemistry and how we think and all that
sort of stuff.
So at any point when this was happening
with your mom,
did any doctor say maybe she should
change her diet,
this or that?
Or really
not.
Once,
and again,
I've been to all of the most storied,
you know,
US news and whatever that the annual
ranking of hospitals in America is that
we were at,
we went to the top hospitals to try to
find a diagnosis and not once was,
um,
diet mentioned at all and you know,
there's,
there's not conclusive evidence on how
diet can affect somebody who has the
disease,
although it's starting to bubble up in
the,
in the literature.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
you know,
exercise wasn't really mentioned even
though exercise is one of the best ways
to treat,
you know,
one of the actually,
um,
the,
uh,
um,
the guidelines for treating mild
cognitive impairment.
We're literally just updated two weeks
ago,
uh,
to,
you know,
to include exercise as a means of
treatment for people with mild cognitive
impairment,
which is sort of like pre dementia which
often converts to diseases like
Alzheimer's disease.
But yeah,
so I became,
I became fixated on,
on these sort of alternate approaches to
treatment and even possibly prevention.
Um,
when I,
when I had that experience with my mom,
because I've always been a big believer
in the power of Diet and lifestyle,
I've just seen it play out in my own
life.
I mean I go to the gym and I'm a
different person walking out of the gym
and I am walking into the gym.
I mean whatever cobwebs I have in my
head are gone,
you know,
excised like the demons,
are excised with a good workout.
And yet,
you know,
that's not something that I feel like is
common wisdom.
So when this all happened to my mom,
I started researching and I realized
that there's a lot of,
you know,
insight out there both in terms of risk
factors for developing dementia.
Uh,
you know,
for example,
take the Mediterranean dietary pattern
which we talked about before,
which is associated with reduced risks
of many chronic diseases.
Yeah.
Can you explain to people what that is?
I mean,
a lot.
A lot of oils.
Yeah.
So it's characterized by being really
high and extra virgin olive oil,
you know,
a glass of wine per day for women wants
to,
for men.
Um,
and then the way that it's typically
defined in the medical literature is as
being a,
it's,
it's defined as being a grain based
diet.
And it all stems back from,
you know,
this one epidemiologist named Ancil keys
who basically,
uh,
in the 19 fifties stationed himself on
the island of Crete,
um,
to look at how that population basically
ate and went about their lives in the
midst of a major epidemic of heart
disease in the United States.
He wanted to see what they were doing
differently in the Mediterranean region
of the world that we might be able to
glean some nutritional insight.
But the problem is he,
and this is a story that's been told by,
you know,
other people.
There's a,
there's a great book called the big fat
surprise with,
you know,
the journalist who wrote it really goes
into depth on the story.
But I talk about it as well.
And Genius Foods.
Uh,
you know,
he was stationed on the island during
lent.
So it was a particularly lean time just
after World War II and his observation
of their dietary pattern was one way,
you know,
it was,
it was predominantly grain based,
um,
but people in the Mediterranean region,
they love fatty cuts of meat,
you know,
I have friends who were born there and
who visit very frequently and they eat
very fatty cuts of meat.
Lamb,
for example.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's all but ignored in the medical
textbook definition of the Mediterranean
diet and also when you're observing the
population as well as what it is that
they're eating,
it's impossible to ascribe causality to
any dietary element because what you're
observing is basically you're,
you're doing just that.
You're observing variables,
but without doing a randomized control
trial,
it's impossible to prove which aspects
of that diet are causally related to
the,
you know,
the phenotypes,
the outcomes that you're seeing in terms
of the population health.
Right.
So,
so that.
And that could partly also just because
of geography and lifestyle,
whether the amount they move around,
if it's cold,
you might need a little more fat on your
bones.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You don't know.
So you need a randomized controlled
trial to do that.
So what I,
what I argue in the book is that what
you know,
what you see in terms of the health of
people living in that region of the
world is not because of the grains that
they're eating,
but in spite of the Greens that they're
reading.
Because when you actually look at what
Greens are,
you know,
it's a whole lot of starch wrapped in a
little bit of insoluble fiber in a tiny
amount of vitamins.
Um,
when building a healthy diet,
we want to really look for things that
are nutrient dense that the brain needs.
So,
you know,
one of the recommendations that I make
to people generally is to consume a huge
salad of fatty salad every single day
rather than eating a bowl of brown rice,
which is pretty nutritionally sparse.
Dark leafy Greens contain a bevy of
micronutrients that the brain actually
needs to create energy.
And there's really good research.
Actually,
a study was just published from rush
university that found that people that
consume a large bowl of dark leafy
greens per day have brains that look on
scans 11 years younger.
Wow.
So yeah,
so mean there's um,
and you also realized with some of this
stuff that you're not missing much
actually.
I mean even just in this week and
whatever that I'm doing this diet,
I got to poke a bull yesterday and I
usually get brown rice on the bottom,
but I got the leafy Greens instead and I
actually,
in a way I enjoyed it more and I felt
kinda slimmer after because yeah,
you're just taking it all that right?
We're going to feel much better.
I mean your body,
you know,
makes a lot of effort to keep certain
things within a very narrow margin.
So for example,
your body temperature is one of those
things that your body works really hard
to keep hovering at around 98 point six
degrees,
right?
The same thing with your blood sugar at
any given time.
You've got,
you know,
one teaspoon of circulating sugar in
your body and your pancreas works very
hard to keep your circulating blood
sugar at that level.
The minute you eat a massive bowl of
brown rice or drink a glass of orange
juice,
which so many Americans begin their day
with,
which contains about six to seven
teaspoons of pure sugar.
You're.
That's like a delusion of glucose being
shuttled straight into your blood that
the vast majority of people don't need.
Whereas that sugar going to go,
most likely it's going to end up on your
hips and your waist.
Yeah,
so basically soft drinks.
I mean I think everyone sort of knows
this at this point in drinks it despite
the knowledge or at least the knowledge
is,
is readily accessible.
So afterwards are pretty much the worst
thing you can drink.
Right?
I mean the amount of sugar there is just
insane.
Horrible.
I mean the.
There's no requirement for consuming a
added sugar.
A lot of people actually feel that they
need sugar to fuel their brain because
of the boost and executive function that
they feel after consuming a food that's
sugary or a granola bar or you know,
any carb rich food,
but really so many people are hooked on
glucose as a fuel for the brain.
That in reality what they're doing is
they're treating their withdrawal from
sugar from the previous meal and that's
why they feel boost.
So basically you have the soda at lunch
and then you,
you're having that crash like two hours
later and you're like,
oh,
I need that bar.
That has.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And it tricks you have tricks,
but I mean it's,
it's,
there's a good reason that you feel
tricked and that you feel like these
foods are your friends because you know,
when you're on that sort of glucose
roller coaster throughout the day,
you need those constant pick me up.
So that's the problem.
So what I think you know is a,
is a more sustainable way of having
energy.
Cognitive resilience is to step off of
that,
that train the glucose train,
and really reacquaint yourself with
healthy fats and foods that are much
lower in carbohydrates and much richer
in the nutrients that your brain
actually needs.
All right.
I want to get down to all the things we
should be eating.
We talked about green leafy things,
but there's a lot more to it than that.
That's what a lot of this is about.
So let's get to it.
If you want to.
Someone's watching this right now.
Maybe they're eating poorly.
Maybe they're eating okay.
Maybe they think they're doing a pretty
good job,
but they want to just kind of reset.
Take them from one.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I think the first thing that people
should do is really cut out the
processed foods,
which is harder than it seems.
You know,
and,
and I definitely,
my heart goes out to people that feel
like they can't give up the junk food
because again,
you know,
these foods are not designed to be
consumed in moderation.
The advice to eat everything in
moderation is horrible in the modern
world,
in the modern supermarket.
Literally our supermarket aisles or are
lined with foods that are designed by
scientists that are paid a lot more than
you and I to to create insatiable
overconsumption and addiction.
Yeah.
Wait,
let's,
let's focus on that for a second because
it sounds like it's not true,
but it's actually true.
Like they actually have people working
on.
Isn't this what they did with Doritos
originally?
I think.
I think that they.
I mean that cool ranch flavor I usually
just to.
I literally used to just lick those
chips.
You don't want to hear your fingers.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So there are literally scientists
working for these companies making you
want more and more and more.
Absolutely.
These foods which now make up against 60
percent of the calories consumed in the
US are designed to screw up your brain
and usually what happens is the
scientist will combine some parts,
sugar,
wheat,
usually with fat and salt,
and it creates this unique mixture of
delectable,
you know,
mouth feel as well as just,
the,
the exact sensation that we've evolved
basically to seek out more of.
It just sets off dopamine,
fireworks and our brain.
Is that actually the same thing that
happens to your brand when you do drugs
and then you need more drugs?
I mean,
is it really the same chemical reactions
that your head?
Yeah,
absolutely.
If not worse.
I mean they've done studies on,
on animals rats for example,
um,
which are all ID basically in rats
provide a really great look into the
behavior that certain foods drive
because you know,
they've got no super ego to,
to steer them from what it is that they
really want to do it.
So they've shown that rats actually
prefer sugar to cocaine,
which is funny because I was really
like,
okay,
rats really like,
okay.
And they really like,
Yeah.
But um,
no,
I mean we tend to think of ourselves as
having had like a moral failure,
right?
Like when we go through a whole bag of
chips or like eat the whole pint of ice
cream.
But again,
like these foods are not designed to be
consumed in moderation.
They're designed literally to have you
finish that whole pint or that whole bag
and then go back as a repeat customer.
Yeah.
I always think the branding of it.
It's so funny to like,
you see all these things like guilt free
chips or don't feel bad about how fat
you are already at this stuff.
And it's like it's all this weird
psychological play to,
to get you to keep eating all this.
No.
Once you pop you can't stop.
It's like a truism with scientific
backing.
Yeah.
At this point.
All right,
so the reset person that's watching this
right now,
that's going to start doing some stuff.
Okay.
Get the process stuff out and that
includes,
like,
that's pretty much all the stuff that
you see in the frozen section.
Like all,
like all of that frozen breakfast stuff
and all of those sandwiches and all
that.
Definitely.
Um,
and actually,
you know,
a really good recommendation for people
that are really trying to make this
change is to first actually,
which is kind of counterintuitive,
but to work on your sleep.
Sleep,
I like to say,
allows a person to getting good quality,
adequate sleep,
gives a person the hormonal fortitude to
make those dietary changes.
So when you,
you know,
when you're under slept,
actually study was just put out showing
that people tend to over consume and eat
excess calories predominantly from these
exact kinds of foods.
So yeah,
optimizing sleep and then
what do they say on sleep?
Like how is it eight hours really?
Is that what they wanted for like the
average?
Yeah,
eight hours is a good amount and that's
also roughly the amount of sleep that
you need to maximize growth hormone,
which is uh,
an important hormone in the body for
preserving lean mass.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
and quality sleep as well.
So I mean not just getting those eight
hours,
but making sure that those eight hours
are really super high quality and we can
get into ways of optimizing sleep.
I guess one of the,
one of the best ways that I like to
optimize my sleep and I find it to be
very effective is to limit my exposure
to screens at night.
Um,
because what time do you shut down?
I shut down.
I try to shut down two to three hours
before bed or if I,
if I'm not shutting down and I have to
work up until the point at which,
you know,
I go to bed.
I mean let's face it,
living in the real world,
you know,
sometimes we have to respond to an
urgent email.
I use blue light blocking glasses,
which I'm a big fan of actually.
And there's good research on amber
colored glasses and their ability to
sort of mitigate some of the loss of
Melatonin.
Do you know,
is that the same effect that the iphone
has now with their night thing?
Is that,
that same thing?
I'm not sure
filter on.
Um,
I'm not sure if it's comparable
actually.
It feel,
it certainly feels way better to my
eyes.
Um,
when night shift is on.
but yeah,
I mean I noticed that when I,
so in my house in New York,
I've got a,
it's my brothers,
I live with my brother.
He has a massive TV.
It's like 85 inches or just one of the
biggest monster is in television I've
ever seen in my life and you know,
he likes to watch movies up until the
point at which she goes to bed and
that's not my preference,
but uh,
I do that with him sometimes and I'll
watch like a movie up until like
midnight or something and I notice that
when I have that amount of light pouring
into my face when I go to bed right
after that,
I'll oftentimes actually wake up feeling
hung over even though I've never,
I've had the eight hours of sleep and I
hadn't had any alcohol.
I just feel under slept and not
rejuvenated.
Whereas when I wear the blue light
blocking glasses and I have no,
you know,
I'm not a,
formally affiliated with any of these
companies.
Don't manufacture them in any sense.
But uh,
but I do find that they work.
I work,
I wake up feeling a lot more refreshed.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that the digital piece of this
is so interesting because I talk about
it with almost every guest.
Just the frustration with social media
and not putting this stuff down and
digital addiction and,
and all of this and it's like,
one of the things that I've tried to do
is I never bring my phone into my room
anymore bedroom where I just stopped
doing it because I realized,
wow,
right before I go to bed,
I'm looking at my phone and then
literally the first thing I do when I
wake up,
before I brush my teeth,
before I go to the bathroom,
it's,
I'm suddenly looking at my phone again.
Like even if it's all wonderful news,
it's probably not an,
it's usually not,
but even if it was,
it's probably not a great way to start
so that.
And I've really,
really been trying to do no technology
on the weekends and I think and I think
that that's really helped.
So is there some sort of connection
between all of that and,
and like just the digital monster that's
affecting our brain to.
Yeah,
I mean there's no yelling,
just like,
you know what I mean,
like something else happened.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I think from a mood standpoint,
for sure.
I mean like you know,
our stress response evolved at a time
when things that were stressful to us
required our immediate attention.
So a bear in your face like this,
like protracted,
longterm psychological stress that so
many of us have,
you know,
so commonly today is a fairly new
invention and on the evolutionary
timescale and the media,
for example,
knows this and app developers,
APP developers know this.
That's why like you turn on any news
station,
local news especially they abide by the.
If it bleeds,
it leads mentality,
put the most anxiety inducing segment
upfront or tease at it at least so that
it causes an expression of a or an
upregulation of norepinephrine in the
brain,
which is basically the brain's focus and
attention neurotransmitter associated
with stress.
And that's something that you know in
it,
it makes you more alert.
It makes you feel more awake.
And so when you read,
know,
doom and gloom news on your,
on your smartphone,
you're basically having the same exact
stress response.
It's funny how when you step away from
it a little bit to how silly it almost
seems.
So like when I get away on the weekend
and then I'm back on Monday,
if I look back at anything that might
have happened and I see all these people
fight,
I'm like,
wow,
you all spent your weekend fighting
about this stuff.
It's one thing that we're doing it on
the weekdays and maybe we can all manage
that myself included.
Maybe we can all manage that a little
differently.
But that endless sort of no way out
thing.
It's,
it's a lot.
It also.
Yeah,
I mean I'm not as familiar with the.
There was a,
there was a study that came out showing
that just having your smart phone around
you is exhausting from a cognitive
standpoint.
You know,
just having it around and sort of
feeling that poll.
We get addicted to it.
I mean it sort of hijacks our dopamine
systems as well.
You know,
being addicted to social media,
that's a real thing.
It's interesting to me though because
people watch this show and we know what
our watch times are and they're off the
charts for for Youtube,
which usually has like a seven second
watch anime or something and that shows
to me that people want long form.
They actually want something that is in
so insulting to their senses,
to their brain.
Now ironically many people are watching
this right now or listening on their
phones,
but a lot of people listen on their
phones while they're doing exercise or
while they're commuting or something,
but I do sense that people want
something else,
so it's like the news is giving us the
local news as you're saying,
they're giving us something we don't
want because they know they'll keep us
there,
but food companies are giving us
something that's not good for us because
they know it'll keep us there.
We now know Tristan Harris,
who I've had on talked about how the
tech companies,
and you just alluded to this,
are giving us things that they know are
bad for us,
so it really is your job.
It's like a full time job now as a human
to be like,
I'm going to do the things that actually
argued for me,
not the things you keep
feeding.
Well,
exactly.
That's why I think it's such a shame
because we each are heir to this amazing
gift,
right?
The human brain.
Yet the modern world is like the hunger
games,
right?
Like attacking it from every which way
and we are not equipped with the tools
to understand,
you know,
what to do to sort of fix that
situation.
And so yeah,
I mean,
I definitely recommend people taking a
break from social media,
from news.
The 24 hour news cycle I think is just
not healthy.
Um,
and then also certainly food.
I think food is a major part of it.
Lifestyle,
you know,
one of the things that I talked about in
the book we go into depth is the fact
that,
you know,
not only are we more sedentary than
we've ever been,
not getting enough exercise a boat,
you know,
there's a,
there was another form of exercise that
we all had for the majority of our
evolution and that is thermal exercise,
you know,
today we live in a time where,
there's chronic climate control,
you know,
and that's something that seems to be to
the detriment of our metabolisms.
So I talk about how you can use,
you know,
cold showers to enhance vigilance.
Um,
which is one of the few things that you
can do that you actually feel a shift in
your consciousness.
Are you big on that?
There are these people that like,
jumped from like the hot tub to a
freezing cold.
I do that.
Maybe it was you that I've heard it.
So I knew what you were,
you took a picture like in a pool or
something.
So it must have been used I think the
first time I saw it.
So what is that?
So you're jumping from hot water,
the cold water in your system is just
like constantly rebooting.
Yeah,
well it's good.
It's called contrast therapy.
So basically,
you know,
when you're.
And a lot of the mechanisms are sort of
conserved between the two activities.
So you know,
when you go into a cold,
when you go into like a sauna for
example,
you're activating something called heat
shock proteins,
which are there to sort of guard the
proteins in your body against a
disfigurement,
which is really important because a lot
of the diseases that we're talking
about,
Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease are associated with
misfolded proteins.
So anytime we can sort of activate these
heat shock proteins seems to be helpful.
Um,
there are also activated when you expose
yourself to cold air.
Um,
yeah,
there's really good.
There's really good research.
A lot of people now are practicing cryo
therapy as a means of enhancing
vigilance,
reducing inflammation,
boosting metabolism,
increasing the proliferation of Brown
fat.
We all have a kind of fat in asset.
It wasn't thought that adults carried it
with them past a,
you know,
a childhood or infancy.
But,
um,
now we know that we actually have this
sort of fat that's actually a good fat,
the fat that we want more of because
it's metabolically active and it burns
calories.
So by going into cold and,
and are keeping ourselves exposed to um,
you know,
intermittent cooler temperatures,
we actually encourage the proliferation
of this,
which is really cool.
So I thought by moving to La and being
an 80 degrees everyday,
it was good.
That was good thing.
I guess it's good for my vitamin D but
for some of this other stuff.
Yeah.
So,
so I think getting back to that,
you know,
I'm having a little bit more thermal
stress in our lives is important.
They've done really good research on
people with type two diabetes and have
found that,
you know,
even mild cold below or higher,
I should say then then what would be
like a freezing temperature,
does it improve insulin sensitivity,
which is sort of the hallmark of
metabolic health.
Um,
which is really interesting.
It's a way to improve your health,
um,
without even doing anything.
I mean,
you can basically just turn the dial on
your air conditioner down a little bit
more.
Yeah.
All right,
so now let's circle back.
This person starts that we're this
imaginary person that we're talking
about this watching right now.
I'm going,
all right,
I'm going to incorporate some of that
stuff.
They're going to get the Eggos Leggo my
Eggo.
You're going to get that out of the way.
Processed food in the morning.
What are they replacing that with your
breakfast for dark this day.
Okay,
let's start the day.
Well,
first of all,
there's no biological need for
breakfast,
so let's just get,
you know,
get that out of the picture.
But I thought breakfast was the most
important meal of the day.
The meal that you break your fast with
is important,
but there's no biological need to eat as
soon as you wake up.
So whether you push that first meal an
hour after you wake up or two hours
after you wake up,
you should be able to do that.
I mean,
breakfast is a fairly new construct in
the evolutionary sense and also when you
wake up first thing in the morning,
your body has a real unique hormonal,
um,
mill you where it wants to burn fat.
You know,
cortisol is at its highest peaks
immediately after you wake up.
And Cortisol is sort of like the body's
fat burning hormone.
It's the body's chief,
catabolic hormone,
liberates stored fatty acids,
sugars,
proteins.
Um,
and so to throw breakfast into that
equation,
especially in the most commonly,
the most commonly consumed form of it,
which is,
you know,
as you said,
like a Lego,
an Eggo waffle.
Yeah.
No offense.
Dad Go and Doritos before you know,
it is naming some things here.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So for the person though that wants to
have something in the morning,
fiber and protein,
so eggs are a perfect foods.
You eat first thing in the morning.
I'm a scramble,
for example,
with some spinach,
Kale and some extra virgin olive oil.
Or You could use a little bit of coconut
oil.
That's a,
you know,
great.
You didn't have a condo.
Are those the two good oils?
Because every,
I feel like every year someone says,
seed oil,
I was good.
Now I know I saw on your website,
get rid of the oil.
Nothing to do with grape seed oil.
Okay,
no problem.
But when you're cooking you.
So basically you're saying oil or,
or you can actually cook with extra
virgin olive oil.
It maintains,
you know,
it doesn't oxidize the way some of these
awful green and seed oils will,
um,
corn oil,
soybean oil,
canola oil,
grapeseed oil.
These are the words.
Yeah,
that's basically like the smoke point
part,
right?
Where it becomes
actually,
interestingly,
and this is a question I get asked a lot
smoke point and the temperature at which
an oil oxidizes there.
There's no relationship.
So smoke point is something that's like
a culinary concern more than anything
else.
And in fact these oils like canola oil,
corn oil,
soybean oil are so heavily processed in
order for them to have a high smoke
point,
but actually they become rancid at much
lower temperatures.
Whereas you take a,
you know,
like a fat,
like butter,
butter will start to smoke pretty early
on,
but it's not because of the fat
oxidizing is because of the proteins and
the case,
the trace a lactose and casein found in
butter,
but that actually has no bearing on
whether or not it's good or bad for you.
So basically though,
if you were making,
you know,
an egg omelet.
Yeah,
use,
use some Kale and spinach.
You're talking about olive oil,
you're talking about coconut oil,
butter or butter.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Um,
yeah,
because you know,
the more saturated in oil is the more
chemically stable it's going to be at
higher temperatures.
So higher heat cooking.
You want to use coconut oil,
butter,
ghee,
Lard,
tallow,
things like that.
My coffee right now it's got and mct oil
and,
and college unit it,
it doesn't really taste like coffee
anymore,
but it's not bad.
College is awesome.
I did a great article deep dive into the
health benefits of Collagen on my
website.
I'm an MCT.
Oil is great.
Uh,
I don't know
really seeing people that have no idea.
MCT Oil,
it's like an extract of coconut oil is.
Yes.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
So mct oil is digested differently than
other fats.
It basically goes straight to the liver
and it becomes converted to Ketones,
which are a sort of alternate fuel that
the brain will readily use when they're
available.
And um,
there's some really interesting research
on mct as a potential intervention for,
for patients with Alzheimer's disease.
Um,
it might theoretically help people sort
of wean themselves off of carbs a by
sort of supplementing brain energy.
Um,
and yeah,
it could also,
you know,
I think just in terms of making you feel
like you've had something,
um,
first thing in the morning slowing the
release of caffeine into your
bloodstream.
No,
that's great.
Um,
but again,
you want to be careful with the added
fats because they're very,
they're not nutrient dense and if you're
trying to lose weight,
there's no need to add a ton of oils to
your diet.
I think that's the irony of where I'm at
with this thing,
not to make this somehow actually have
lost a couple pounds while doing this
very high fat thing.
But I hear what you're saying,
I actually probably could cut down on
that and then my body will go to the
actual instead of the fat and putting in
there
and I don't wanna break it to you,
but the weight that you lost could be
water at the same time.
So yeah,
adding,
adding oils to the,
to break that to me,
I mean this is what you do.
Okay.
So you have,
you have basically
an Omelet,
something to that effect in the morning
with some Greens in there or yogurt,
full fat yogurt,
Grass Fed yogurt.
Um,
you know,
that's something that I think is great.
Can you explain why grass fed is so
important?
Because I feel like there's a certain
set of people that are always kind of
like,
you know,
you go to get grayed out,
you brass bed like that doesn't do
anything.
It's no it.
Well it dictates the healthiness of the
fat,
you know.
So if you're talking about like grass
fed whey protein for example,
makes much less of a difference because
whey protein is just pure protein.
But if you're talking about,
you know,
a piece of red meat or something,
grass fed red meat compared to grain fed
red meat,
it's a different animal even though it's
the same animal.
It's basically one in grass fed red
meat.
You have a ratio of Omega six fats to
Omega three fats that basically mirrors
that of the human brain.
You've got a lot more carotinoids,
which are basically these fat soluble
antioxidant compounds that have been
shown to boost processing speed in the
brain,
which is really important.
Cows that eat grass grass contains these
carotenoids carotinoids which are fat
soluble.
They become embedded in the fat of the
cow.
And so when you eat a piece of steak
from a cow that's been grass fed,
you're eating those carotinoids along
with fat that helps you absorb it
because they need fat to be absorbed.
So I mean,
it's a really healthy food when,
you know,
when we're talking about grass fed meat.
And then in terms of Yogurt,
grass fed yogurt,
full fat can have,
you know,
a few Omega threes.
It's not a major source,
but it's got Cla,
vitaminK ,
two M,
much higher in grass fed,
in the fat of grass Fed Full Fat Yogurt
Than Conventional Yogurt.
I feel like lunch is the hard one for a
lot of people at work.
A lot of people are barely leaving their
desks at work.
Even for me working from home even,
but I'm so busy during the day,
it's like,
oh,
we just got to grab something or get
chipotle a or whatever it is.
What,
what can you do in the mid day?
You can have a relatively healthy meal
at chipotle.
Chipotle is still,
you know,
I think in all of their options has
uses,
you know,
one of those oils,
green and probably canola oil.
I'm not,
I'm not sure which.
But yeah,
I mean you can get guacamole there,
which is certainly very healthy.
Um,
avocado is incredible for you.
It's again packed with carotinoids.
I'm on.
Avocado has twice the potassium,
have a banana,
which is amazing.
People think about potassium.
They only think about bananas.
I'm very low carb food.
You can get some protein a and then the
salsa I think is fine,
you know,
so you can.
And the bell peppers are great.
Um,
but generally what I tell people for
launches,
it's a great opportunity during the day
to eat a salad.
I think people should be eating a large
salad every single day.
Uh,
again,
the research is pretty compelling and
you know,
mechanistically it makes sense that dark
leafy Greens would be really good for a
person.
They are the most nutrient dense foods.
There are,
meaning there's tons of nutrients for
very few calories.
They're packed with dietary fiber,
you know,
will not only help fill you up,
but it feeds the microorganisms that
live in your large intestine.
This is called the microbiome,
which is a really exciting focus now in
research.
Um,
and you want to make that solid fat and
I don't mean by putting,
you know,
tortilla strips and ranch dressing and
cheese on it,
uh,
or even commercial salad dressings.
You really want to avoid those.
But there was no better vehicle for
extra virgin olive oil,
then a salad and extra virgin olive oil.
Going back to the Mediterranean dietary
pattern,
it's a hallmark and they've done
research,
randomized controlled trials where they
look specifically at extra virgin olive
oil.
One of the,
you know,
the sort of best studies to look at was
done out of Barcelona,
Spain called the pre med study where
they gave subjects a leader of extra
virgin olive oil,
extra virgin olive oil to consume per
week and they found that,
you know,
at the end of the trial,
went on for six years,
they had improved cognitive function,
they had improved risk factors for
cardiovascular disease and they even
lost weight.
So by adding more fat to their diet,
they ended up losing weight.
Although it was extra virgin olive oil,
it wasn't butter.
Okay.
So now we've had the Omelette started
the day.
We've had a big green leafy salad for
lunch.
Maybe some protein in there.
What's happening in for dinner.
Yeah.
So for dinner,
I'm a big fan of grass fed red meat.
I think that's one of the more
controversial tips that I give people
because meat has sort of been in the dog
house for so long,
but I thought one day a week or red
meat.
No,
I mean,
the thing is I don't.
There's no,
you know,
there was a really great study performed
by Charlotte Newman at Ucla where they
gave a.
It was again a randomized controlled
trial.
They gave children in Kenya,
um,
this a traditional porridge dish made of
beans and green beans and things like
that.
Um,
you know,
what a control group had just the sort
of vegetarian version.
Then they gave a group,
uh,
the,
a version with dairy and then they gave
a group a version with meat and they
found that the kids that were given,
uh,
the version with supplemented meat added
meet actually at the end of the trial,
had improved cognitive function and
signs of mental health.
So there's other research actually from
a that I site engineers,
foods from Australia,
Deacon University,
where they found that women who didn't
consume the nationally recommended three
to four servings of red meat per week
actually had twice the risk for
depression or anxiety or mood disorder.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I think it's,
there's a,
what's called like a u shaped curve.
I think definitely some red meat is
better than none,
but eating too much isn't great either.
You definitely want to have a diet
that's rich in vegetables,
dark leafy Greens,
Kale,
spinach,
things like that.
But in that context,
I think that eating properly raised meat
is definitely a definitely healthy fatty
fish for dinner would be another,
another option,
fishes packed with micronutrients that
the brain needs to create new cells,
which we now know the adult brain can do
up until death.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of options.
I think,
you know,
when you look at a plate,
you want to have half of it,
vegetables and half of it and meet.
I don't think eating,
one of the,
I think incorrect interpretations of the
Paleo Diet is that it's meant to be a
really high meat diet.
Um,
I think that ignores a lot of the
research now again,
surrounding the microbiome,
which is this area that's very new,
but,
uh,
you know,
we want to get a good amount of dietary
fiber,
micronutrients,
which the brain needs,
um,
and there's no better way to do that
then with,
than with veggies.
So
how often do you cheat on this stuff
because I'm guessing a certain amount of
people that are watching this going,
all right,
this is what this guy does for a living.
He's writing books about it,
you know what I mean?
He has the time to prepare meals the way
he wants,
etc.
Etc.
How oftEn do you go off the deep end
and,
you know,
I mean that on something a couple times
a year.
But,
you know,
I think I think I'd have the cravings
for ice cream or I don't to be totally
honest and I,
I've always had a huge sweet tooth.
Um,
but I,
yeaH,
I don't really.
Once I made the transition to a lower
carb diet,
I don't have those cravings.
In fact,
I can comfortably go hours without
eating.
I think that's a really good subjective
sign of metabolic resilience.
What about alcohol?
Where does that fit into this?
I know you mentioned the one glass of
wine for a woman.
What are they one and a half to two
wants to for men per day?
Yeah.
D is that basically align with what
you're.
There's some researchers recommend
consuming red wine.
It's part of the sort of mind diet,
which is a dietary sort of pattern that
was created at rush university,
but I don't know,
I think,
I think it's hard to study alcohol
because on the one hand it's such a
powerful social lubricant and feeling
connected to one another.
Um,
and of course,
you know,
as a solvent for stress,
I think it's really powerful.
Um,
and that's not to be discounted,
you know,
we live stressful lives and there's sort
of no way around that for,
for many people,
but ethanol is a neurotoxin and I think
if you're,
if you have a way of dealing with stress
and feeling connected with,
you know,
with one another,
without it,
I think you're probably better off doing
that.
But I do give some tips in the book
about how to make consuming alcohol as
healthy and experiences as possible.
You want to avoid sugary mixers.
I think beer is one of the least
healthiest,
um,
alcohols that you can consume.
Um,
you always want to follow the one for
one rule,
you know,
chase every drink with a glass of water.
And also,
you know,
alcohol is a diuretic and when you pee a
lot you excrete sodium.
And so by replenishing those
electrolytes,
uh,
you know,
while you were drinking,
I think that's really important.
So sprinkle a little,
a little bit of salt in your water,
for example.
It could Be one way to do that,
right?
People don't realize that like you don't
need down a gatorade just because he
lost a couple of electrolytes was
literally just a little salt in your
water.
A little bit of salt.
Yeah.
Um,
I actually became,
I've become really interested in salt.
I,
uh,
yeah.
I can.
I carry a little vial of salt in my gym
bag now and after a good sauna session
or workout,
I sprinkle a little bit in my mouth,
huh?
Yeah.
Because you lose,
you lose.
People are not going to be happy.
They're not gonna.
Be happy about that.
You lose,
especially when you're on a low carb
diet.
When you drop the carbs,
your Insulin comes down and insulin
basically tells the kidneys to hold onto
sodium.
know unnaturally.
So for people that are on a really hIgh
carb diet,
which most most americans are consuming
300 grams of carbs a day with insulin
levels constantly elevated.
They're holding onto excess sodium.
So the recommendation to watch your
sodium intake In that sort of context
makes a lot of sense.
But if you're eating a low carb diet,
as you should focus on whole foods that
are not,
um,
packed with starch,
you really need to be mindful of not
only your sodium intake because again,
sodium sodium's a nutrient.
It's not this poison that,
you know,
you would think it was looking at the
labels of,
of,
you know,
processed foods that are low in sodium
and that's somehow supposed to make it
okay that you're eating,
you know,
tons of sugar and processed wheat.
Um,
yeah.
So you need to really be mindful of
that.
And then you do other things in your
lifestyle that,
that accelerate the,
um,
the spilling of sodium.
So like exercise,
drinking coffee,
which causes you to pee out a lot of
sodium.
I did a great interview with a
researcher who focuses on this topic and
uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
it's an area of interest for me and
definitely when I,
when I wake up in the morning,
if I'm doing like one of my really
particularly low carb phases,
I'll sprinkle,
you know,
a little bit of salt in my water and it
makes me feel,
it gives me like a boost of energy I
feel like.
Yeah.
Interesting.
All right,
so let's go full circle here.
So basically about six years ago,
that's when this all started and,
and your mom was diagnosed,
he obviously changed her life
afterwards,
changed your life.
Uh,
where's your mom at now and how have the
things,
everything we've talked about,
because this last hour,
how have you been able to incorporate
them into her lIfe and,
uh,
and see,
see some changes.
I mean,
you know,
I've,
I've tried,
especially when I moved from la back to
New York,
I,
uh,
I really tried to take a,
you know,
super hands on approach for as long as I
could with my mom to change her diet and
certainly some,
some aspects of her diet has changed.
but,
uh,
you know,
dementia is a horrible disease and it
makes it really hard on both the patient
and the caregiver,
uh,
to,
to adhere to a strict dietary
interventions.
You know,
there was a study that I was that I dove
into recently where they put people with
alzheimer's disease,
both mIld to moderate alzheimer's
disease on a ketogenic diet.
And they found that one of the major
limitations of the study is that
adherence is so high to,
you know,
to these diets and it's a major stress
on the caregiver.
I'm not my mom's caregiver,
but I'm at a certain point I had to kind
of teach and step back,
you know,
so that,
if I am around my mom and she's craving
something that isn't max approved,
it doesn't affect my relationship with
her.
Because first and foremost,
I love my mom and I don't want to do
anything to compromise the relationship
or her quality of life.
So
I wonder is there any work done that
people with dementia,
I can sort of remember this from my
grandmother who had dementia and I spent
a lot of time with her her last few
years that she was an incredible cook,
used to cook all sorts of exotic things,
but in her later years as the dementia
kicked in,
she really only wanted the same few
things.
Is that,
do you think somehow connected to like
there's just certain things maybe that
are still in the memory,
like,
like she really suddenly wanted to
chicken soup all the time,
but I don't remember really her having
chicken soup for many years before that
she would cook these crazy meals.
Yeah,
I mean the only shift in food preference
that I'm familiar with is a shift
towards a sweeter foods which occUrs and
it's thought that that happens because a
brain with alzheimer's disease is
essentially being starved of it's,
you know,
one of its primary energy substrates,
which is glucose.
So there's thIs notion that alzheimer's
disease is a form of diabetes,
of the brain.
It's essentially become unable to
properly process glucose.
That's where ketogenic interventions
have shown a lot of promise and it's
thought that that might be really
helpful for a patient with alzheimer's
disease.
Um,
and one of the thIngs that,
that sort of strengthens that,
that notion is that they,
that people,
you know,
that that perhaps never expressed a
preference for sweet foods or had a
sweet tooth begins to crave sugar and
it's sad that that's sort of the brain
crying out for sugar as a means of
creating energy.
But the irony is that those are the
exact kinds of foods that drive
inflammation and insulin resistance in
the body and that are so detrimental to
the brain to begin with.
There's really,
there's really interesting,
yOu know,
and ketogenic diets are a,
I think they've become a little
buzzworthy these days and popular,
but there's a lot of good research on
them.
they're hard to study.
There's not a lot of money to go around
to,
to really,
um,
to study them.
But there's good evidence that actually
one of my friends,
uh,
published a study on patients with mild
cognitive impairment where putting
patients with mild cognitive impairment
on a ketogenic diet seem to improve
cognitive function and then just
recently that was extended to patients
with alzheimer's disease,
which we were all waiting for.
We're all waiting for a ketogenic trial
to be performed on patients with
diagnosed alzheimer's disease.
And it seemed that for the patients that
were able to adhere to it,
there was a sIgnificant improvement in
their cognitive function when they were
on that diet.
And they went back to their baseline
level of cognitive function after the
trial ended,
which really strengthens the notion that
ketones were helping the brain sort of
as an energetic life raft.
It seems that the main takeaway here is
do some of the preventional work
completely.
Again,
you know,
alzheimer's disease begins in the brain
30 to 40 years before the first
symptoms,
uh,
before the first symptom.
And there's even some data suggesting
that this could be a lifelong thing for
people with certain genes that put them
at higher risk for alzheimer's disease.
Like the apoe e four allele,
which one in four people carry?
Yeah.
Uh,
well it's a pleasure to see you.
You become a master of your craft and I
think it maybe has a little something to
do with what you're eating.
I mean,
you're,
you're pulling information pretty
quickly.
So I think you've,
the proof is in the,
uh,
gluten free pudding or something like
that.
GenIus foods comes out March 20th.
Yes.
See,
I memorized that.
That was pretty impressive.
And that brad had your documentary
that's in the works right now.
That's in the works.
That'll come out at some point this
year.
Um,
people can check out a kickstarter
teaser@breadheadmovie.com.
We'll link to that right down below.
And genius foods is,
is up for preorder now.
I mean,
it's going to be everywhere.
Books are sold.
So thank you.
All right,
well,
it's been a pleasure.
I think doing this with you while I'm in
the midst of this diet and you've given
me some ways that maybe I can change it
a little less fat and uh,
we'll,
we'll revIsit this privately and a
couple of weeks and then,
and then we'll do this again for sure.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Well for max,
follow him on twitter.
It's max luca b or l u g a v e r e.